Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so it was just
confirmed were going to be seeing new Justice
League footage really soon.
They didn't say exactly which day.
But there are a couple solid bets, just because
Fantastic Beasts another big Warner Bros.
franchise which is going to get 5 movies is
coming out this weekend and Ben Affleck has
a big movie coming out this December during
Christmas weekend so I'll explain that and
talk about the Death of Superman because we
are 1 year away from Justice League coming
out.
It's coming out November 17, literally this
day next year, which is also coinciding with
the 25th Anniversary of the Death of Superman
in the comics, what a coincidence.
So Justice League footage here's what we know
Fantastic Beasts is being released this weekend
so if we do not see a new Justice League Trailer
tomorrow or in the next couple of days like
next Tuesday I would plan for it to drop with
Ben Affleck's movie at the end of the year
that movie is called Live by Night he just
plays this really bad ass gangster it's set
during Prohibition Era it stars Zoe Saldana
who is Gamorah.
So that's being released literally on Christmas
day December 25 so a lot of you remember that
there was a rumor earlier this year with the
really get a whole bunch of trailers on a
bunch of days in the next couple of months
so one of those was the Justice League Trailer.
It was supposed to drop around that December
25 date.
So my bet is is that they're attaching some
Justice League Batman footage to another Batman
related film so to speak one of the cool things
that's different now about the way studios
drop trailers than say even like a couple
years ago is that they'll drop like a really
quick teaser or a picture or they have a social
media account that will just start posting
weird stuff that will lead up to them dropping
footage so like way back in the day all they
would do it just like drop the one trailer
and that said that they would do anything
else but now because like all the different
social media platforms you'll start to see
like weird stuff happened on their accounts
before they actually do something really big.
So will actually be a little bit easier to
know when it's gonna drop when we get within
like a week of it.
So because we still haven't seen a whole lot
about it I'm just planning for that Christmas
weekend and were still like a long ways off
from hearing about the Batman movie.
But I know a lot of you are asking about the
rumor that the script was trashed likes there's
like somebody in Hollywood who is saying that
there was a lot of problems with the Batman
script in the studio supposedly didn't care
about it because they knew they would make
so much money on it internationally in the
reason that I didn't do a video for that is
just like a weighted literally waited a day
to do a video for it.
Just explain what was going on in the person
who was trashing the script came out and profusely
apologized probably because he was worried
that Ben Affleck would come to his house and
punch him in the face or that the studio would
never work with him again because the person
was Brett Easton Ellis who's actually been
directing like one of the.
YouTube.
Read original series, so that gives you an
idea for like his current status in Hollywood
he's directing Youtubers so he that someone
inside the Warner Bros. circle of trust is
not inside the Batman circle.
So he hasn't read the script and he was really
just reporting some gossip that he heard secondhand
from another person who is also probably not
in the know to the whole thing was just a
bunch of garbage.
Don't worry about at the Batman movie is fine.
I think that's part of the reason why we haven't
seen Jeff John's be more active on social
like every once in a while he'll post something
but he's actually been pretty quiet this past
year but mostly I think that's because he
and his wife had a baby and because he's now
in charge of all these DC films.
Meaning that he probably never sleeps but
supposedly like this new Justice League footage.
The stuff is going to be different from previous
Justice League trailers is it'll just feature
a whole lot more Aquaman because everybody
behind the scenes is saying that Jason the
Moa is just killing it, which sounds about
right, especially from the stuff that we've
seen so far and he looks like he's having
more fun than anybody else on that film set
so whatever ends up happening I will totally
do a video the minute we find out exactly
when were getting new footage and what's going
to be in it.
So in related news, you probably know that
they're doing a live action Justice League
dark film Guillermo Del Toro was originally
going to do the whole thing himself.
Now he still on as a producer.
But they did just released a new trailer for
the animated Justice League dark which stars
Matt Ryan as Constantine and Batman's and
it.
So I'll just play that trailer here and we'll
talk about what's going on with that
Get them! They're everywhere!
These crimes were committed by law abiding citizens
They all have seen nightmare visions beforehand
The same pattern is repeating around the world. So there could be an overriding paranormal element.
are you talking about magic?
then we have to find John Constantine
So if you guys can see Jason M'ara who is
currently on Agents of Shield is doing Batman
Matt Ryan is doing Constantine which I thought
was really cool when we found out about that
back during Comic Con if you're not familiar
with Justice League Dark is basically like
a Justice League team up based of the magic
characters in the DC universe.
They did like a big new 52 title and now they're
kind of spinning it into a live-action thing
but we also have this cool movie coming too,
so the animated team in this movie is Constantine
Batman Zatana Etrigan the demon Superman and
Wonder Woman who are not part of Justice League
Dark they're part of the regular Justice League
team just like Batman Richie Simpson who is
a Hellblazer character he kind of comes with
Constantine Felix Faust who's one of the villains
of Justice League Dark then Destiny who's
actually being played by Alfred Molina he's
actually character from the Sandman comics
Neil Gaiman Sandman and then Swamp Thing who's
one of the weirdest coolest characters I've
always been hoping that they would work into
the live-action universe of eventually but
he was a big part of that in the comics and
then Black Orchid.
So it just like a really weird cast of characters
in a really fun storyline that will kinda
get you prepped for live-action Justice League
Dark in a couple years that's a little further
off.
So once we get through the live-action regular
Justice League movie will probably hear more
about that.
So the regular movies I think Warner Bros.
just wants people to focus on the current
Justice League roster and then they'll weave
in more magic based weird stuff with Justice
League Dark but this movie the animated movie
is coming out January 24 on video on demand
in the DVDs dropping February 7, so let me
know what you guys think about live-action
Justice League and live-action Justice League
Dark.
Do you think they'll actually end up doing
it or do you think will just get postponed
indefinitely because they been talking about
doing a Justice League Dark movie for a long
time now like Guillermo Del Toro worked his
ass off for the last 10 years, to try and
get something going but either way it new
Legends of Tomorrow posting tonight.
There is a DC giveaway that's going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so I'll
post that video after the episode airs tonight
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the big behind the scenes Justice
League Trailer and you can click here for
the trailer for the big 4 night crossover,
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!